what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts diney and Shoals like completely
went at it man start sorry Steinberg man
I love you bro like don't don't text me
middle of the night upset but milk
release the pot
Andrew Schultz is back in the news this
week after the story of his unreleased
full sun podcast interview has swarmed
the internet for those of you who aren't
familiar full sun is a popular podcast
Under the nelk Umbrella hosted by Kyle
full guard who you might recognize from
his appearance on this past weekend the
show has over 2 million Subs on YouTube
and is a massive platform in the world
of podcasting which is why nine months
ago Andrew Schultz decided to appear on
full send to promote his new special
infamous which was coming out around
that time you're a Taliban
go home bro you're free
you're not really Taliban you're just
Afghani
you're from Pakistan that's not even the
same you racist [__]
the first time the existence of this
unreleased episode became public
knowledge a few weeks ago it was
suggested by John Shahidi the president
of happy Dad that steiny was the one who
didn't want the episode to air because
he had gotten into a heated verbal
exchange with Andrew Schultz and nelk
was keeping it unreleased for Steiny's
sake and I was like who is this Chicken
McNugget asking me now the full sun
podcast is interviewed O.J Simpson
Donald Trump Caitlyn Jenner they're
definitely not afraid to stir the pot
which is why it's almost unbelievable
things got so bad between Schultz and
steiny in this interview that they
decided it couldn't be seen by the
public in any capacity but there was an
episode with Andrew Schultz man Starry
Steinberg man I love you bro like Donald
don't text me middle of the night upset
but the Schultz went after like you know
I think you know when like a stand-up
comedian like looks in a crowd and
decides like just go after somebody well
I think like Schultz was kind of like
went out to steiny and it was pretty
awkward was it the whole episode or was
it like it was a bulk of it it was like
no you couldn't cut around it or he
would come back to it and like he just
wanted to go after steiny anyone who's
at all familiar with Andrew Schultz as a
guest on podcasts can probably imagine
exactly how this all went down a
majority of his funniest interview
moments come from busting balls with his
guests or with the host of whatever show
he's a guest on which works great when
you're talking with professional
comedians but apparently things got a
bit contentious with this tiny character
who is now claiming that Andrew Schultz
is actually the one who asked for this
episode to be cut in the first place
basically when we did the Pod with
shawls I don't know exactly what
happened between you and him or whatever
but I think the vibe was just off for
some reason I don't know if it was like
all your fault but either way steiny and
shawls like completely went at it I
don't even know if I went back at it I
think he thought that like he didn't
really know you that well as well
I think he knew me and he knew Steve and
you were kind of just starting out well
that's the thing that you want to
realize this was [__] filmed seven
eight months ago yes steiny and Shoals
went at it because I think shulls
thought that you were like digging at
him first for certain [__] so then he
was chirping you back and then you guys
just kind of went at it for like five
minutes and then shells was going in on
steiny and stuff like that and then
after the podcast shawls just kind of
approached me and John and said yo like
I don't know if that was really it like
I feel like if I want to be on the Pod
like we could do something way bigger
and some [__] that's like really gonna
break the internet you didn't want it
out either at all okay well let's that
that's that's for sure the reason okay
that's but that's also not exactly true
because I remember saying like yo bro no
you don't know no no this is okay okay
no no you're way more accepting now yeah
for sure but back then you were like bro
no I that's gonna cause like you to not
allow me real quick but what I did say
was can we maybe take certain things out
and we could put it out and you said
yeah sure I
someone realized that like Kyle and
Stein don't really know me right right
that well because the questions they're
asked they're asking are like really
basic question what's an example has
anybody ever like heckled you
there's a moment upon I don't know if
they added
like like have you ever like talked to
someone in the crowd
and like
so I'm thinking so I'm thinking two
different things in this moment I'm
going
either they have no clue who I am and
that's weird that I would even be here
annoying yeah or
they know and it's a troll
so I'm I'm like hmm
do you know what I mean like and you
know you know in that moment
steiny Gaga you got Clips
you can kind of tell just based on the
way they're talking about this thing
that steiny actually might have got his
feelings hurt and might be still a bit
defensive about the whole situation
which is honestly not a huge surprise
we've seen this happen before when
Comics go on these massive YouTube
podcasts like impulsive or nelk these
shows get millions of views every
episode by interviewing some of the
biggest celebrity names in the world
they have a brand of edgy humor and can
definitely create some funny moments
here and there but overall they are used
to being in control of their show and
rarely make themselves the butt of any
jokes which might work well with most
normal guests but it's twice now that
we've seen this exact format go horribly
wrong when an actual comedian who's used
to Comedy pods goes on a show like this
both Andrew Schultz's appearance on full
send and Bobby Lee's episode of
impulsive ended with one of their
co-hosts getting salty about jokes made
at their expense in fact Bobby Lee went
so hard on the co-host of impulsive that
he ended up walking off the episode out
and quitting the show forever which I
guess is worse than not releasing the
episode at all there's certain
he is clocked out yeah yeah I know
George has been under a tremendous no no
stop George I want you over here with me
George I want you over here and chase
him down
you find him George no go get him go get
him he I try I said this he walked and
that's a first and now we're gonna have
to deal with the Fallout of this episode
I swear to God Bobby Lee you've pissed
off my co-host he's probably crying in
the driveway
you know the Beatles could have lost
Ringo
oh yeah
oh man apparently since this drama has
become public Kyle and Andrew have been
texting about filming a new version of
the podcast soon and even reacting to
some of the clips where stymie and
Schultz were going at it but even in the
clip of the milk boys discussing redoing
the Andrew Schultz episode steiny still
looks uncomfortable and said he's cool
with running it back as long as Schultz
keeps that same energy yeah no my how do
you feel about having him on yeah and he
could keep that same energy but the
thing about it what does that mean like
if he wants to come at me like that's
fine but the thing about it was are you
angry with him I mean at the time I was
just confused because like typically if
like I'm going back and forth like how
he would treat like the Theo Von one
when we're just joking right like I can
tell like it's funny when we're like the
banter's there but when he's kind of
like going at me and like no one's
reacting and it's like awkward because I
totally forget what the actual specifics
oh I remember like it really what was it
well no one was like really like
laughing or like I was laughing I don't
think you were I was I don't think you
were but I like I like when people argue
you no but it was I just I just everyone
comments but I just sit back and like I
just it's so it's okay but I will tell
you like you even said like it was just
so such a bad episode and it was so
awkward that it was just like it I was
confused now I don't think these guys
are lying but it is kind of hard to
believe that Andrew Schultz said he
doesn't want this podcast out at all to
me it sounds like he was just getting on
stymie's ass making funny jokes at his
expense and steiny took it too
personally at the time also the fact
that they've been mispronouncing his
name throughout this entire thing tells
me Andrew scholes might not be chomping
at the bit to break the internet with
these guys anytime soon Andrew Schulz
Andrew Schulz oh yes
ymh Studios announced the addition of
another new podcast last week called not
today pal which will debut on their
Channel this Thursday this announcement
comes just one month after adding a
fifth show to their Network first date
with Lauren Compton which is already
averaging 320 000 views through four
episodes what do you wear to sleep
nothing
just falls out balls out what does your
girlfriend wear to sleep uh usually
she'll wear uh uh she'll wear a little
top little t-shirt that's cute and uh
that's about it yeah yeah
um yeah that's it that's what she wears
I thought there was something else no
there's no no pants no no nothing ever
do you mean another couple no pants
party it's a no-pass party and uh and
and nobody can come except for me
what now that sounded horrible this is
the first date nobody talked like that
nobody talked like that on a first date
so I guess we know how you feel about
open relationships the new show
announcement took place last week on
Instagram with your mom's house saying
quotes we're very excited to announce
our newest podcast not today pal with
Jamie Lynn Sigler and Rob Eiler former
TV siblings from The Sopranos Jamie Lynn
and Robert have polar opposite
personalities but always find hilarious
ways to reach Common Ground the first
episode drops Thursday July 20th at 7
A.M Central Time anywhere you get
podcasts guest spots from last week The
Joe Rogan Experience had on Brian
Simpson Tony Hawk was on are you garbage
why Mage talked with Tom Papa Kyle
Dunnigan was a guest on Whiskey Ginger
killed Tony this week was with Ari
shaffir two bears one cave was Bert and
Joe McHale flagrant did not have a guest
Kirk Fox was a guest on the Harland
Highway Rosebud Baker went on stavy's
world Ali Sadiq was suggesting we might
be drunk and Rick lastman was on bad
friends
stop
[Music]
come on do it
come on that one is a great place to do
it
please do it
you can't ask it's gonna happen I'll
tell you one thing
after the podcast okay this past weekend
with theovan was a solo episode Tom
Segura was on being in with Jordan Tampa
Tony was a guest on Chrissy chaos Dr
Drew went on hey babe Greg fit Simmons
on the Honeydew Ron White was on first
date Paul Walter Hauser went on take her
shoes off Seth Meyers was on the blocks
podcast Roy Wood Jr and Keith Robinson
went on you know what dude Ari Spears
was on tigerbelly Dan Soder was on only
fans as far as new stand-up specials are
either out now or coming out soon Tom
Segura Sledgehammer is still trending
right now on Netflix we also made a
reaction video to that last week so
check it out if you haven't seen it yet
Kevin Hart's new special reality check
is up on peacock we also have Rob
Schneider woke up America and Mark Ellis
alive and well both out right now and
some really exciting upcoming specials
Jeffrey asmus's debut special the only
funny white man comes out on YouTube
this Thursday and according to him it's
quote the first 100 Alpha comedy special
ever released
he did
that's my [__] search on the internet
I can't see it in the flesh I'll bust a
little load I think I like that a lot
I'll be dribbling Catholics you think my
name's [__] goofy dude we're also
getting closer to the release of Mark
Norman's First full Netflix special Soup
To Nuts which will be streaming
worldwide July 25th everyone seems to be
really excited for Mark's new special to
drop next Tuesday we're definitely gonna
be making a video recapping Soup To Nuts
they'll come out soon as well as a Mark
Norman try not to laugh compilation if
you don't want to miss those videos
consider subscribing to joke world right
now and I promise you that you'll be in
the comedy Loop for years to come also
check out the link in our Instagram bio
if you want some free stickers sent to
you in the mail thanks for watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out